and some breaking news to bring you this
hour in the last few moments it's been
confirmed that the duchess
of cambridge has been at the band stand
on clapham common taking a look at the
flowers and the tributes that have been
laid
in memory of the missing and abducted
sarah everard you can see her there in
the green coat just taking a moment like
so many women have
to pause and reflect and remember
well let's bring in emma birchley who
joins us live from clapham in
south london um interesting to see the
duchess of cambridge there
just a woman one of many women who will
have been moved by this case
yes the duchess of cambridge clearly
felt that like many
here she had to come and
bring flowers and read the messages that
have been left the organizers
had decided this morning to cancel the
vigil
because they couldn't get the permission
they needed from the metropolitan police
because of
of the coronavirus rules and instead had
urged people to
light candles tonight at half past nine
on their doorsteps and
they were hoping uh that it would mean
that that there wouldn't be any issue
with people gathering but actually
people clearly felt the need to come and
there's a real
sense of somberness here people
standing just looking at the displays
and in in places you look around and you
see people
uh weeping now the organizers
had been raising money which they were
going to use to pay the fines
that they would expect to get for
organizing events there were 32
vigils planned that they knew about
around the country
each organizer could have expected a
fine of 10 000 pounds so they had a
target
of fundraising three hundred and twenty
thousand pounds now when that
crowdfunding
page began this morning uh
they started at zero pounds it's already
at two hundred and seventy two
thousand pounds so people clearly
feeling very strongly they wanted to
come here to remember sarah
but they also wanted to come with that
message that
uh women are fed up with feeling
intimidated
harassed and there's a real sense that
more should be done that
if they make a complaint action
is taken and that the legal process is
seen
through to the end so people here
gathering the vigil actually wasn't
meant to have started
until six o'clock even if it had gone
ahead